- But I noticed you have a tattoo.
I have 17. (laughs)
- I don't have tattoos,
I have stretch marks.
- I have those too.
- Depending on how I move,
I can change the figure.
- Very cool.
- The characters look
different when I shift.
- I have a couple tattoos
that are super suspect
at this point.
- Right.
- [Kelly] They look different.
- Well, what about that guy?
Funky.
- [Kelly] Yeah. He's
getting my name tattooed.
- I know.
- [Kelly] He's gonna regret it.
But what's yours?
What does your tattoo mean?
- Don't you think it's rude
that he has so many tattoos
and he didn't ask you of
us, for our autographs?
- Like really, please can we bring that up
when he comes back?
- Yes
- He actually, he recognized
me but he confused me
for being someone else.
- No
- Sign that person's name.
- That happens to me all
the time, you'd think..
Seriously, I've been asked so many times
or they'll be like, Oh my gosh
I love your song, So Small.
And I'm like, I don't
even know that that is.
- What is that?
- And then I find out,
it's Carrie Underwood
and I'm like, and then
I'm like, thank you.
(crowd applauds)
- Cause I'm like legit a 100 lbs heavier
than Carrie Underwood.
So I was like that can be
lot, yeah I'm just saying
it's real different though.